a whole guys look we just got a delivery
here yeah this is gonna be awesome
[Music]
[Music]
that little sucker actually goes pretty
good it does about five miles per hour
both boys in it but we can make it
faster
[Music]
were those little cars fun yeah well I
think we need to do some upgrades
starting with nerf gosh we're gonna take
this nerf blaster it's the prometheus
it's the largest most powerful nerf gun
money can buy right now and we are gonna
modify this and put it on that car
you excited run dance Maggie is so much
more accurate than the dart gun this
thing holds over 200 rounds in the
hopper and takes seconds to reload it's
also got a rechargeable removable
battery pack so this thing is just
awesome
let's take a look inside this is the
guts of the nerf gun you've got a little
motor here that feeds an auger and a
conveyor belt that takes the balls from
the hopper and puts them in between
these two spinning wheels and they spit
out the balls the same way a pitching
machine does you've got a little switch
in here this is where the hopper clicks
into place and it won't work if the
hopper is not properly shut and clicked
into place you've got your battery
housing right there and up in here
you've got a series of switches there we
go if you have these two switches here
this one revs the spinning wheels here
and this one moves the augurs here but
this one won't work unless you're
depressing this switch so we got all the
switches free for the handle there's a
low battery light we'll put that aside
for this to work I need to replace this
switch and this switch unfortunately
these switches have like three wires
coming out of them the switches I want
to use have two wires coming out of them
one of these wires is connected to the
motherboard and I think the motherboard
is not necessary
so I'm going to chop it off and see if
it still works and if it does great if
not huh we're gonna have a problem let's
see what happens when we cut it well
that well let's cut some more wires and
see what happens I'm much less certain
about what to do with this switch I need
to get rid of one of these wires this is
the negative to the battery this is the
positive to the auger motor this goes to
the switch that detects whether the
hoppers installed so my best guess is we
clip this one it still works I don't
know why there's these extra wires but
it still works
uh-huh okay that so now we've removed
the motherboard and the low battery
indicator light alright that is the guts
make sure it still works still shoots
first things first we need to build a
new housing for this thing
[Music]
this is the hopper switch unless it's
depressed the whole thing doesn't work
so we're going to just go ahead and do a
low-tech solution
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now all I gotta do is make another
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I really want to put a rocket
launcher on these cars it'll shoot these
nerf missiles so I've got an electronic
solenoid hooked up to my hundred psi air
compressor here and we're gonna test it
out and make sure it doesn't explode and
kill the children
it would just as far as I was hoping
and it didn't explode that's a success
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go okay I got the rocket
launchers up now I'm going to install a
two and a half gallon air tank to shoot
the rocket
alright let's test it
[Music]
look at that we got 100 psi whoa
go it over the bush all right guys you
ready to go test him out hey head on up
the hill
[Music]
finished a rocket launcher got all the
leaks fixed it holds 100 psi and uses
about one PSI every time you hit the
button it'll shoot rockets down to about
20 psi so you've got about 80 shots with
one tank now that I finished with that
beast I've got to modify this one and
I'm gonna do something a little
different all right this is a 12-volt
battery and we're going to replace it
with this 24 volt battery yeah
[Applause]
well putting a 24 volt battery in a
12-volt car isn't that complicated but
you have two problems one is it puts a
lot of wear and tear on the motors
especially when you're accelerating
because the pedal is only an on and off
switch it's not like the gas pedal on
the car the other problem is then it'll
give the kids whiplash and they'll pop
wheelies and stuff because all of a
sudden you hit that pedal and instantly
you get 24 volts of power so all these
complicated electronics solve that
problem first off this knob puts a delay
on acceleration so there's a one-second
delay where it takes one second to go
from zero to full speed or you can go
five seconds from zero to full speed so
it accelerates gradually the other thing
it does is it has like a dimmer switch
here which can govern the maximum
voltage use you can either use all 24
volts or you can go at 50% use 12 volts
or 25% and only use 6 volts so depending
on the age of the kid and the train
you're using you can dumb it down we're
having hit it at 75% in two seconds to
start off with
[Music]
they're doing burnouts I'm gonna make it
accelerate a little slower and I'm gonna
take the power down just a little bit
okay
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
Paul even a girl that's juiced up
another modification I made this is a
kill switch so if the kids get too far
or driving too dangerously
I can remotely turn off the car these
are wonderful I got to figure out how to
install these into the children oh I
might have wired that wrong all right we
have the second car tricked out now we
got to add some guns and I'm gonna do
some more modifications for this one
instead of modifying the housing I'm
gonna be modifying the guts instead of
completely gutting this like I did the
last gun I'm going to simply give it
alternative methods of powering it
alternative triggers and alternative
flywheel triggers come on there we go
all right let's give this a quick test
[Music]
getting really hot now why is that stop
and reevaluate what have we done oh this
battery is melting whoa yeah this is
making noise let's get this outside
something is up with that well the
battery was smoking and overheating
which is what happens when you take a
wire and you hook up the positive
directly to the negative of the battery
so I'm guessing what happened is that
one of the wires associated with the
auger switch is creating a feedback
where the the electricity is going from
the battery back into the battery and
that's what's causing the problem so I
think I need to clip some of the wires
that clipped before I think it's the
brown one let's try that all right so we
learned a valuable lesson
definitely definitely cut the brown wire
now we mark it all right that's the
battery ah darn it I screwed into my
fingernail I'll just wipe my fingernail
blood and goo off my drill bit and we'll
keep going
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right I got the plug for the trigger
the flywheel in the battery and I've got
each one with a different connector so I
can't accidentally get them crossed this
is the lipo 3s battery I'm gonna use to
run the gun and lipo batteries you do
not want to over drain them so I've got
a voltage alarm then I'm gonna plug in
here and let's and just for a little
extra safety I'm gonna put the lipo
battery inside fire-resistant pouch
there plug that in let's see what
happens oh we got one more modification
for the gun this is the stock hopper
which holds 200 balls this right here
was 3d printed it's called the god
hopper it holds about two thousand balls
and it slides like so check it out it's
got two spring-loaded ports back here
for dumping balls in and this thing is a
beast one final addition an ammo can
with extra nerf balls this thing is
loaded
[Music]
here tom get over there great holy
mackerel that things on steroids whoo
that is uh that is a powerful thing
right there yeah there you go man
yeah I think we're ready to do a nerf
battle all right guys you ready to catch
this out ha ha ha all right go for it
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'll start it's smoking oh yeah
you're just smoking good yeah Tommy's
back wheels completely seized up
there we go
[Music]
well we burned out one of Tommy's motor
and we used up all the battery on
Nathan's car but we had a great time
didn't you guys have a great time
what Oh No well guys we ended up
shooting about 3000 nerf balls and a lot
of you are wondering how on earth were
gonna clean this all up I've got a trick
this parking lot only has two storm
drains and we covered both of them up
with wood
three thousand rounds and a little bit
of trash picked up in no time at all but
I'm gonna get these cars home and work
on upgrading Tommy's gearbox if you'd
like to see me use these cars in future
videos make sure to click that like
button so I know that this is something
you guys want to see also shout out to
Adam Savage
with the YouTube channel Adam Savage's
tested if you ever want to make a nerf
weapon mech suit you know just give me a
call email me something hey guys did you
have a good time yeah if you guys like
these types of videos we've got tons of
building projects like the floating
fishing cabin we did a few months ago
and we've got tons of nerf more videos
too if you like that sort of thing so
definitely click Subscribe we put out
new videos every Saturday morning if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get those engage
thanks for watching dad's working on the
cars there yeah